margate was among 101 towns from across
england selected a bid for funding from
the government's towns fund initiative
this is a once-in-a-generation
opportunity to invest in local projects
drive growth and improve the environment
for the benefit of the whole community
the town deal comes at an important and
exciting time in margate's history the
town has faced its challenges over the
last 50 years and now is the time to
come together to make sure it has a
thriving economy 365 days a year
at the heart of the town deal is the
town investment plan which sets out a
long-term vision and strategy for
margate the investment plan makes the
case for a 29 million pound investment
supporting projects themed around four
interlinking interventions these build
on what makes margate so special and
deliver change that will benefit local
people and visitors for years to come
margate's growing creative and cultural
economy is an opportunity not to be
missed the first intervention is
therefore a nine million pound
investment in scaling margate's creative
production and skills it will establish
a creative land trust to support
projects stretching from the high street
to the theatre royal building spaces for
creative production and education
potential locations include the former
marks and spencers primark and other key
sites within the high street investment
will bring life back to the town centre
linking the coast to the historic hawley
square and establishing a creative
economic hub driving jobs skills
education and engagement
in its heyday margate was known as a
place for well-being and tourism the
second intervention is a 6.5 million
pound investment in coastal well-being
to support projects across margate's
coastline creating new and surprising
experiences for visitors establishing
better links between the town centre
north down road and the coastline will
deliver an improved network of
connections and encourage people to
explore beyond the seafront
the third intervention focuses on public
realm and connections with a 4.5 million
pound targeted investment in the town
centre coastline and residential areas
making it easier to get around and
improving visitor amenities this will
better connect north down road to the
town centre and create attractive public
spaces as well as enhancing cycling and
walking infrastructure
margate's past has a role to play in its
future the fourth intervention is
therefore a nine million pound
investment in well-loved heritage assets
and will help secure a sustainable
future for the dreamland cinema complex
and the winter gardens which benefits
the wider town
it will create new enterprise and
cultural spaces for both visitors and
the community it will also support the
development of feasibility plans for the
future of important landmarks including
the arlington arcade the old town hall
and the lido
the town investment plan has now been
submitted to the ministry of housing
communities and local government thank
you to everyone who took the time to get
involved and share their views we're
currently waiting to hear back from the
government and in the meantime the town
deal board and project team continue to
work in partnership with stakeholders
local businesses and the community
you can read the tan investment plan in
full keep up to date with how the deal
progresses and sign up to receive news
at margate
dot
towndeal.co.uk